we've so far talked about the IBM 9020
which is this big beast up here and that
really had two functions we've talked
about flight data processing which is
the information about what the aircraft
intends to do but the other major facet
of this is radar data processing so you
can look at it at point of view that the
flight plan tells us what the aircraft
intended to do the radar tells what it's
actually doing and they're not
necessarily the same thing there's all
sorts of reasons why the flight doesn't
actually follow the original flight plan
it can be juicer weather it can be due
to congestion there's all sorts of
reasons this was the first time we were
able to bring the two together flight
and radar data processing but that was
all this did it just did the processing
somehow we have to display all of that a
lot so we're now total over here and
this is an early example of a radar data
processing system it's called the
process radar display system and
essentially what happened was that radar
information which is pure this is a
radar plot of this particular aircraft
with no other real information
associated with it would then be routed
to this equipment which would then be
responsible for determining which
controller needed to see it so
effectively doing the routing but then
also down at the bottom here one of the
world's earliest graphics cards the
pdp-11 34 which was just simply there in
order to take the radar data and
actually work out how to paint that onto
the radar screen vector graphics drawn
rather than raster drawn and a very
early example of a graphics card and
that in turn done a jolly great long
cable would feed to this kind of a
display here this is actually a slightly
later display but it's the same sort of
general type of display all that's in
here is really the technology that's
required to take the the graphics
generated positional data and actually
paint it onto the screen these screens
were outrageously expensive I think
they're in the tens of thousands of
pounds back in the 1970s and they were
also rather easy to break as well
so we were always very very careful with
these these are all different radars
that can feed in so you've actually got
a switch up here that selects the
different radars and because this could
be running a what's called bypass mode
so their control is to how you stood in
the old days the controller would select
whichever radar gave him the best image
for the area that he was
trying to work on and those are the
various enroute radars so you'd have to
at least two of these screens sometimes
more than for each sector so this is a
sector display a sector varies in size
depending on what's going on there's
some sectors like for example the London
TM a terminal moving area which is
really quite small because there's an
awful lot of stuff going on as you get
further and further afield so the
sector's get larger and larger the other
thing that can happen is the sectors can
change shape between different times of
day and so on so for example at night
there's much less air traffic and
therefore controlling it is much easier
so you can make the sector's bigger and
then as the traffic starts building up
in the early morning as the lights start
coming across in the states you make the
sector smack smaller again and that's
something else which we were able to do
as a result of introducing computers
into it this idea of dynamic particle
allocation of sector size which before
then had been really quite difficult you
might have heard of occasions when
there's been a few hiccups with the air
traffic control sensors and usually it's
to do with changing the size of the
these sectors but again the codes been
in there for a long time now I think
we've got pretty well all the bugs out a
bit the controller would use this
rollerball to for example highlight a
particular aircraft and draw a vector to
indicate how far away he would be in
five minutes time or something like that
this predates the mouse really but in
fact in some respects is probably a
better system they are still using
rollerball technology for radar display
systems even to this day because it's in
one place it never moves I was up at
restrict control center just about a
year ago and watch them using this to
work out they've got a radar paint sort
of showing that the aircraft is
such-and-such and and we know what speed
he's going at so we can then draw a
vector which says that's where he's
going to be in five minutes time which
allows them to see whether he's got any
issues with collision avoidance or
anything like that and also to just get
the timing sorted out these the
controller is trying to vector this
aircraft onto the instrument landing
system so it's a useful idea if he can
sort of say I will be at such-and-such
place in five minutes time or two
minutes time whatever so this is a very
early example of the radar display using
the data from the IBM 9 to 20 that
sounds ever so easy there was actually
lots and lots of steps along the way and
in fact it took many years before the
radar data was really
focus by the IBM 1920 and displayed in
native form on this this type of display
there was also bypassed systems because
like all of these things we don't want
it failing so there's always there's
always standby systems and standbys to
the standby systems and so on and a lot
of that had to be implemented for the
for the raid artists side of things as
well refreshing well it's affected being
refreshed all the time because it's
affected graphic strong system but the
radars typically rotate one rotation
every four seconds so you're only going
to get an update in terms of the radar
date about every four seconds and what
you actually see is like a little you
see a blob where the aircraft is and
coming off that there's a line and then
a box and in that box you've got
information about the aircraft its
altitude the aircraft callsign its type
where it's going from where it's going
to do whether its ascending or
descending if you've looked at
flightradar24 they do a very similar
thing that's using a thing called a ESB
which is a broadcast positional
information system from commercial
aircraft and effectively plotting that
using servers and then you can pick that
up on the Internet
so and what they've done is they're more
or less followed the same kind of radar
display appearance as you would have
that intro Center I think it was
something of the order of 100 so it was
quite a big investment and a lot of real
estate as well were those sorts of
things I don't know to be honest I think
they were probably in the quite a few
thousand pounds each type of a category
so no there would be there have been
large chunks of million pounds worth of
equipment there but back in those days
hardware was very expensive yes the
whole idea was that everything was
resilient so and of course this wasn't
the only place we were using computers
the computers were were coming in to air
traffic control in just about every
every sort of capacity this is the kind
of radar display that we have today
and essentially all of the hardware
that's required all the computing and
all the processing that's required for
this sector is actually built into the
display now everything's connected
together with fiber optic
networking isn't a problem anymore so we
can actually afford to have the the
processing out in the display other than
that it's
it's exactly the same type of display
still the vector graphics display
because that gives you a better quality
of image and the screens are still
outrageously expensive this is the sort
of thing that they'll be sitting in
front of at Swannack there's also a
brand new control center up at Cheswick
as well which does from 55 degrees north
broadly speaking the Scottish border
what's interesting to note is as another
example of resilience is that the
Prestwick with a certain amount of
hassle could do all the work that's
being done at Sonic and Sonic could do
all the work that's being done at
preswick it would take a bit of doing
but if for any reason one or other of
the control centres was unable to
function then the whole of the air
traffic control in the UK could be run
from one or from the other
one of the things that I decided that
try and do is to write a game where the
computer played Monopoly and you can see
here the high speed printers these
printers would run at 600 lines per
minute
I wrote this whole thing in assembler
the computer would make a move and it
would then print the Monopoly board so
this thing was throwing up pages like
mad